I think the real thing that's changed
that's alarming and also was pretty easy
to predict was how long do you want to
wait for a plumber right so the
conversation used to be
let me talk about the myths and
misperceptions to keep people out of
Plumbing so people who might want to
jump into that trade will benefit and
then it was well let's talk about some
of the stigmas and the stereotypes the
key parents and guidance counselors from
promoting these trades because now we're
just getting in our own way yeah today
it's just how long do you want to wait
for a plumber or an electrician yeah
today and this is what I I sort of hoped
would happen because I think it's the
final step in writing the ship we have
to have people who don't work in the
trades
or who don't employ trades people to
realize that they nevertheless have skin
in the game right and they have to be a
part of the conversation and that is
like I don't want to wait six months for
a plumber that's right that's when it
gets personal